LILIONEL CARMANT, ministre
dédélégué à la Santé, Québec
- - On vient de visiter le CLSC
SaSainte-Catherine, très content
dede ce qui se passe. 23 persons
vavaccinées aujourd'hui :
dedes jeunes de la rue,
dedes itinérants. Ils ont vraimt
fafait un tour de roue assez
exexceptionnel en peu de temps.
PuPuis, on espère que la campage
vava s'amplifier au cours
dedes prochaines semaines.
5 540 000 adultes québécois.
C'est le nombre de personnes que
lele gouvernement veut convaince
dede se faire vacciner dans
leles prochaines semaines,
nonotamment avec les cliniques
épéphémères présentées par le
miministre Carmant et déployées
ddès aujourd'hui dans les régios
dudu Québec où les taux de
vavaccination sont plus bas.
MaMais qui sont exactement
leles Québécois non vaccinés?
LaLa Dre Mélissa Généreux et
l'l'Université de Sherbrooke
sese sont penchés sur la questin
pependant plus de deux ans.
JeJe me suis entretenue avec
elelle un peu plus tôt.
D Dre Généreux, bonsoir,
bibienvenue à 24/60.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On dit beaucoup que cette
cicinquième vague est celle des
nonon-vaccinés contre les vaccis
etet le gouvernement déploie
totoutes sortes de mesures pour
coconvaincre les gens de se faie
vavacciner. Mais vous, vous avez
vovoulu u comprendre le phénomè,
cocomprendre ces non-vaccinés,
ququi ils sont. Qu'est-ce que
vovous avez découvert?
DrDre MÉLISSA GÉNÉREUX, prof.,
mémédecine, Université Sherbrooe
- - En fait, je trouve ça
inintéressant qu'on parle des
vavaccinés contre les non-vaccis
paparce c'est vraiment
cece qui venait me chercher,
cecette sensation-là de clivage,
dede division qu'on risque de
sesemer dans la société, alors
ququ'au contraire, on a besoin
d'd'une cohésion. Donc je tenais
àà examiner un peu de plus près
ququel est le profil des non-
vavaccinés pour voir est-ce que
c'c'est vrai qu'on peut tous
leles mettre dans le même panie.
EsEst-ce qu'ils sont tous ultra-
cocomplotistes et très méfiants,
cocomme plusieurs semblent
l'l'entendre? Et effectivement,
nonos données ont montré
ququ'il n'existe pas qu'un prof,
mamais bien plusieurs profils de
pepersonnes qui ont fait le chox
dede ne pas être vaccinés.
- - Une étude menée auprès
dede près de 11 000 personnes,
onon un tableau très bref, votre
ététude est beaucoup plus élarge
quque ce qu'on va montrer en
tatableau mais c'est intéressan.
SuSur ce fameux 10 % là qu'on dt
nonon vacciné, on va voir
leles chiffres, 65,3 % ont un ln
pepeut-être avec une vision
cocomplotiste contre 35 %
sasans vision complotiste.
QuQu'est-ce qui définit
cecette vision complotiste,
DrDre Généreux? Qu'est-ce qui
lala caractérise?
- - En fait, la visision comploe
c'c'est basé sur une échelle qui
esest validée internationalemen,
seselon laquelle on pose
cicinq questions. Êtes-vous
d'd'accord avec chacun de ces
énénoncés-là? Et c'est comme ça
ququ'on détermine ceux qui, some
totoute, ont plutôt une vision
cocomplotiste versus une vision
ququi est non complotiste.
GeGenre d'exemple, à quel point
jeje pense que le gouvernement
meme cache des choses au sujet e
lala COVID? On ne me dit pas toe
lala vérité. Il est grand temps
ququ'on mène une grande enquête
popour savoir le fin fond de
l'l'histoire liée à la soi-disat
papandémie.
D Donc ce genre d'énoncés là,
sisi les gens ont tendance
àà plutôt être d'accord avec ça,
enen moyenne, on va dire qu'ils
onont une vision complotiste,
mamais c'est important quand mêe
dede dire ici que vision
cocomplotiste n'égale pas
lele complotiste typique vraimet
asassumé, qui est très actif,
enentre autres sur les réseaux
sosociaux. On peut avoir
ceces idées-là de façon plus
momodérée sans pour autant êtren
cocomplotiste très, très assumé.
- - Mais en fait, ces gens-là,
leles complotistes très affirmés
sosont omniprésents sur la scène
acactuellement. On les voit même
dadans une manifestation qui se
prprépare pour les prochains jos
àà Ottawa et ils ont encore
ininfiltré le monde
dedes camionneurs, et tous
nene sont pas des complotistes,
bibien évidemment. Mais au fond,
ceces gens-là, qu'est-ce qui fat
ququ'ils ne reconnaissent même s
lala pandémie ou la COVID?
QuQu'ils puissent croire en fait
quque le vaccin injecte une puc,
enenfin, que le vaccin, c'est un
cocomplot également des grandes
phpharma. Qu'est-ce qui explique
cece raisonnement-là?
EsEst-ce qu'on le découvre
àà travers votre étude?
- - Une chose qu'on a
dédéfinitivement pu mettre
dede l'avant, surtout lorsqu'on
cocompare les non-vaccinés qui
n'n'ont pas du tout cette vision
cocomplotiste là, c'est la manie
ququ'ont les gens de s'informer.
DoDonc, du côté de ceux qui ont
unune vision complotiste,
onon voit qu'ils ont beaucoup ps
tetendance à aller s'informer,
auau sujet de la COVID évidemme,
susur les réseaux sociaux, sur
leles plateformes comme YouTube,
auauprès de leurs proches, de
leleur entourage et beaucoup mos
auauprès des sosources officiel,
cocomme évidemment directement
auauprès du gouvernement ou
leles médias traditionnels.
D Donc ça, c'est quand même
unune différence assez flagrant,
jeje vous dirais, entre les deux
grgroupes et je pense que ce que
çaça souligne, c'est que le fait
d'd'aller chercher ces sources
d'd'information de manière très
ininformelle, sans que ce soit
dedes informations validées,
pepeut venir évidemment renforcr
nonos croyances erronées et
alalimenter un peu notre vision
cocomplotiste.
- - Est-ce qu'il y a un profil
sosocial particulier chez
ceces complotistes-là?
- - En fait, c'est intéressant
paparce que je travaille avec
dedes gens en sciences de
lala communication et en sciencs
popolitiques dans ce magnifique
prprojet-là, si bien qu'on a eu
l'l'idée d'insérer des questions
susur l'idéologie politique.
EtEt je trouve ça assez
inintéressant de dire que chez
nonos non-vaccinés avec une visn
cocomplotiste, on a beaucoup pls
dede polarisation politique. Doc
dedes gens un petit peu plus de
drdroite en moyenne, évidemment;
auau niveau socioéconomique, en
momoyenne des gens qui ont moins
sosouvent un diplôme collégial
ouou universitaire, qui ont
dedes revenus familiaux un petit
pepeu plus faibles.
MaMais encore une fois, je veux
fafaire attention pour ne pas
memettre tout le monde du même
ccôté parce qu'on voit qu'il y a
unune bonne variabilité,
ququ'on peut avoir quand même
dedes gens très éduqués, des ges
avavec des très bons revenus
ququi adhèrent tout de même
àà des visions complotistes.
MaMais vous voyez quand même
unun peu les grandes moyennes,
leles grandes tendances.
- - Et comment arriverait-on à s
coconvaincre de changer d'opini?
OuOu si c'est peine perdue,
ququ'on doit plutôt s'attarder
àà cette autre catégorie
dede non-vaccinés, sans vision
cocomplotiste. Comme le souhaite
lele gouvernement, au fond, c'et
d'd'atteindre le plus grand nome
dede personnes non vaccinées
popour... Parce que pour le
gogouvernement, la vraie liberté
esest du côté du vaccin, c'est
lala seule façon de sortir
dede la pandémie.
- - Bien moi, je pense que
lele choix, la cible de convaine
leles gens le plus rapidement
popossible, le plus de gens
popossible, c'est peut-être là
ouoù ça accroche, parce que
sisi c'est ça notre cible ultim,
d'd'y aller rapidement, le plus
dede gens possible, on va y allr
avavec les moyens forts, peut-êe
momoins la méthode douce.
JeJe suis contente d'entendre qe
trtranquillement, on se dirige
vevers une approche plus positi,
ququi va aller à la rencontre ds
gegens, favoriser le dialogue.
PaParce que je suis convaincue
ququ'au long terme, on va avoir
bebeaucoup plus de retombées
popositives, même si ça va peut-
êêtre être moins rapide
cocomme retombées en termes
dede couverture vaccinale qui
auaugmente, de prendre le temps
dede dialoguer avec les gens, de
s's'intéresser à ce qu'ils vive,
dede ce qui les motive ou
leles démotive par rapport à
lala vaccination et tout le res.
EtEt ça, ça peut vraiment aider
àà rétablir un lien de confiance
d'd'abord et avant tout.
EtEt ensuite, peut-être commencr
àà partager de l'information
vavalidée scientifiquement
popour voir si ça pourrait pas
ininfluencer. Mais je pense que
dede convaincre à tout prix, c't
pepeut-être pas la posture idéa,
susurtout pour les gens qui
papartent avec une vision
unun peu plus complotiste.
- - En terminant, Dre Généreux,
onon sait que les vaccinés qui t
prpris toutes les mesures de
prprécaution pour éviter la COVD
sosont habités eux aussi par
unun sentiment de frustration,
dede colère, parfois même de vor
leleur propre liberté à eux brie
papar les gens qui ne veulent ps
êêtre vaccinés. Le gouvernement
leleur tend la main, on en a paé
totout à l'heure, mais tout
àà l'heure aussi, Dr Boileau,
enen point de presse, s'est fait
dedemander : "Est-ce qu'on en et
rerendu à l'obligation vaccinale
cocomme le permettrait la Loi
susur la santé publique?"
IlIl a tout simplement répondu :
"O"On n'en est pas là."
QuQu'est-ce que vous pensez
dede cette option qu'aurait
lele gouvernement d'imposer
l'l'obligation vaccinale?
- - Bien, je pense effectivement
ququ'on n'en est pas là et
çaça s'est beaucoup perdu dans s
dedeux dernières années en raisn
dede l'état d'urgence sanitaire,
ququi est maintenu depuis
dedeux ans, mais il n'y a rien
ququi nous empêche d'établir
unun dialogue avec la populatio.
DoDonc vaccination obligatoire,
popour moi, c'est quelque chose
dede quand même gros qui touche
bebeaucoup de gens dans les
vavaleurs, les principes éthiqus
etet tout ça. Et minimalement,
d'd'avoir une consultation,
unun échange avec la population
etet les grands acteurs dans
leles régions, les différentes
cocommunautés, ça m'apparaît
esessentiel parce que c'est quad
mmême une mesure de force assez
imimportante qui peut engendrer
auaussi des inégalités assez
imimportantes au niveau social.
DoDonc c'est un  pensez-y-bien.
- - Là-dessus, Dre Généreux,
memerci de cette enquête.
MeMerci d'avoir... de nous avoir
écéclairés là-dessus.
AuAu revoir, à bientôt.
- - Au revoi